so let's talk for a second about the the
nature of this election when it comes to
demographics so there was an assumption
that i think really began to take hold
in 2012 uh rather than 2008 i think that
if if the country does end up coming
apart over the long haul and our
optimism is unjustified i think that
people are going to look back to the
election of 2012 as a seminal moment
um mainly because it was the moment when
barack obama shifted
pretty openly from the candidate who was
going to unify americans into a
candidate
who openly wished to divide americans by
class and by
racial group and by sexual preference uh
and then
to cobble together a coalition and it
was going to be this coalition of the
ascendant over
over the rest of this uh over the rest
of america and democrats
seem to wed themselves to this argument
the sort of demographics is destiny
argument that as america became
plurality minority
uh that america would would turn more
blue in the process
what trump did uh and it's it's fairly
incredible considering
that the lead attack on trump was that
he was a vicious horrible white
supremacist and racist
is he won a historic number of latino
votes he won a historic number of black
votes
he seems to be realigning a lot of the
demographics in the united states is
particularly true
in in florida it was certainly true in
texas the most hispanic district in
america
96 hispanic district in texas went 5247
for biden which is
astonishingly high performance for a
republican in a district like that
55 of cuban americans voted for trump in
this last election cycle
in florida by the exit polls uh he he's
he outperformed
and you can see democrats starting to
panic over all of this
uh what do you why is it that you think
that trump
maybe the most by conventional wisdom
unlikely person to break the demographic
stranglehold that democrats were relying
upon ended up
starting to make serious inroads into
breaking that demographic stranglehold
i don't want to be too tripartite but i
think there were three reasons the first
is he substituted class for race and
that's a fluid concept
and he basically really worked hard at
lowering minority unemployment as one
guy said to me i was on a roof
a mexican-american guy said i was on a
roof hammering and for the first time in
my life two people came by and yelled at
me get down on the roof i'll pay you two
dollars more an hour
and i said so what he said nobody's ever
bid on my labor before i had to go bit
so he gave people dignity by class
considerations
and it basically was very threatening it
basically said
if you were a poor mexican-american guy
or poor white guy
in tulare or a poor black guy i'm going
to worry about you
and i'm not going to be offended or i'm
not going to be apologetic to oprah or
lebron james
because all of these wealthy elites of
any color
are on that side of the class divide and
i'm with you in the other
and the second that that took a lot of
authenticity so
you can't can you imagine donald trump
said i'm so tired
like hillary he'd never do it or i'm
going to put you all in chains
he never modulates his accent uh i
talked to a guy
he came during the first campaign to
talk to a bunch of wealthy farmers i saw
one of them i said what was he like did
he have the caterpillar hat on
the you know the blue levi's no no he
had
the whole thing he had the orange skin
he had this tie
he had the suit it was 107 degrees he
had his
black wingtips and he he is what he is
i said did he change his accent straw in
the mouth no no no
queen's accent or whatever it is they
didn't know
and so people feel that he's authentic
and that helps
so he's not a billionaire anymore he's
authentic
and he actually seems at ease with with
middle class people
as one guy told me you know trump is not
adverse to getting in the ring with
anybody because he's actually been in a
ring he's been in a wrestling ring when
his
you know his uh entrepreneur days and
world wrestling and all that stuff
so that's the second thing that he's
he's authentic and he substituted class
and then he hit on something that was
very rare
and i think this is something that these
people have no idea he
he got the i he got on the idea that
these very wealthy upscale progressive
liberals
the university professor the hollywood
entertainer
the media anchor person people don't
like them they don't like their
comportment they don't like their accent
they don't like their condescending
manner
and trump made fun of them and that
really resonated
with minorities who don't like them
either but they felt that they were
indebted to them or they had to
in a quid pro quo fashion vote for them
but when you talk to people and they see
trump
i think jason woodlock said on national
tv a lot of black
young men like trump because he doesn't
care and he he has a certain image
i guess it was a machismo image that's
not so much my point my point is that
that nasal sounding pajama boy life of
julia
elite trump doesn't like and he's
he he attacks them he makes fun of them
and a lot of minority people say you
know what
i don't want to be told what to do by
those guys anymore they're just
antithetical to my religion they're
antithetical
to my family um they're antithetical to
what i do in my own life
and they never they've never you know
they've never overhauled a car
they've never been in a bad situation
they don't know how people live and i'm
going to listen to those guys
and he hit on that and they thought it
would be impossible because they kept
saying he's a billionaire
it wasn't a matter of money it was a
matter of attitude
and authenticity to dig in on that a
little bit one of the things that
that is so astonishing here is that the
conventional wisdom and that's really
what trump's
career has been about is blowing up
conventional wisdom in a variety of ways
um most many good some bad but you know
when it comes to his
when it comes to uh the conventional
wisdom the conventional wisdom in the
republican party after 2012 when there
was real underperformance with latino
voters
is that republicans needed to make
extraordinary concessions on illegal
immigration
in order to win the hispanic and latino
vote and start making inroads
the evidence simply was not there for
that considering that republicans in
texas
are not exactly open borders fanatics
and yet they were winning an outside
share of the hispanic and latino vote
in texas and hispanic latino vote in
florida
was cutting much heavier toward
republicans
than it was in california and in
california california republicans have
tended to be
much softer on illegal immigration than
maybe some of their compatriots in other
states
and yet after 2012 there was this report
that came out it basically suggested if
you want to make inroads with
with latino americans then the best way
to do that is to
make concessions on immigration here
comes trump and he says i'm going to
build a wall
there are a lot of criminals crossing
the border i'm going to deport people
who are
criminals and then i'm going to deport a
bunch of people who are here illegally
and i'm going to set up new immigration
standards and then he ends up winning
more of the latino vote by leaps and
bounds than mitt romney ever did and
it's not particularly close
so why do you think that is is that does
that just speak to a fundamental
disconnect in the in the psyche of most
human beings
between policy and attitude and his
attitude just mattered more or is it
that
maybe everybody is sort of getting the
conventional wisdom wrong and it turns
out a lot of
latino americans don't particularly like
illegal immigration just like a lot of
black americans don't like rioting and
looting
i think it's the latter i think a lot in
the republican party
uh we're very insular they're in an echo
chamber when they talk about
hispanics it was uh you know yolanda who
does my uh
does my hair and i give her my extra
clothes or it was jose who
cuts my grass and i talk to him and they
don't get out and
put their kids in the same school with
them live side by side with them talk to
them every day
and when you do that you hear a whole
different world i
last week a woman i saw her on the
street i used to know her pretty well
mexican-american i said what's going on
she said oh i just got back from mexico
to see my dad's house i went down to
oaxaca
there were other people in it they just
took it over
we couldn't do anything but she goes
that's mexicans for you that's mexico
and then she said
and then i got pulled over twice because
they called me a gringa
because my spanish is pretty rusty and
they detected an american accent they
called her
basically what we call a gringo and so
she said i was so happy to get back here
i just saw another guy at the lumber
yard this morning and he said
this is the funniest he said victor what
the hell has happened and this isn't
mexico
what are we doing i came up here to get
away from this stuff this election
it's like mexico and i said i know it is
and so my point is that it
they're just all of these minorities are
just people
and they're no better or no worse than
white people they're just people
and when you either have this
condescending attitude or you have this
elitist idea that
you think that you know exactly what
they want rather than
would i want my kid in a school where
they had to get rid of the ap
classes because no one spoke english
because they all came in from mexico we
had
english this sec would i want my kid in
a school where m13 or nortenos or cerano
gangs
were beating people up if their spanish
had a detectable american accent in it
would i want to live in a neighborhood
when they shoot people and then the guy
gets out with no bail and he comes back
and he tries to shoot me because i was a
guy that called the police
and these are all things that happen
every day and so when they see trump
and you're right close the border and
when he added you know we'll do
something with our daca people
and things that drive the left really
crazy
about trump when he says i love the
mexican people
i love mexican people or he'll say our
farmers or
i gotta we gotta help our vets that
first-person plural possessive
hour our doc our daca kids they think
nobody goes
yeah they do because he shows that he
has an empathy and he likes to be with
people so
republican party they kept saying that
the
limousine liberals were condescending
but boy a mitt romney a candidate
that was not going to happen and i'm not
taking anything against
away from mitt romney but you can see he
almost won and he almost won because a
lot of deplorables said you know what i
can't take obama and i'll vote for this
guy
uh not enough of them but there's a
there's an opportunity here to
recalibrate
not only race in america but the entire
republican party
is the party of the middle class of
minorities
uh fighting against a party that of the
very wealthy and the very poor
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show sunday special if you
did
go ahead and hit the subscribe button so
you stay up to date on all of our future
content